this is not the kind of weather we're
used to seeing around labor day weekend
but still plenty of people are heading
here to las vegas to see attractions
like the showgirls here behind me so we
went out today and talked to tourists
and locals to see how they're dealing
with this heat and staying cool
being from michigan this is definitely
some serious heat it may be september
but the heat is on as temps continue to
climb
we live in las vegas so triple digits
are nothing new but it is pretty late in
the year to see this kind of extreme
weather so we asked locals and tourists
how they're handling it staying cool and
drinking lots of water we get some
drinks and we
come to the water park heather herb is
here to get married on the strip and had
to change some of her plans thursday as
we hit 108 degrees we were going to have
a rooftop party and welcome party for
our guests but with the heat we had to
move it inside tayla thompson is all
about the water as she and her child
have been trying to find some relief at
local splash pads past days has been
super hot but being around this water it
feels so good so whether you're taking
advantage of the ac we try to weave in
and out of the places enjoy the air
conditioning or make the pool your go-to
move
it's a good time to get creative and
push through this last bit of the
scorching summer we're hoping to be a
little cooler
we've been sharing these tips a lot but
they always are bearing repeating of
course it is important to stay inside
the hottest parts of the day usually in
the late afternoon stay in that air
conditioning keep hydrated and of course
make sure to take breaks in the shade
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now